У майбутньому від цієї зброї може залежати, хто виграє війну.
Це автономна зброя, яка зможе визначати, обирати  й атакувати цілі без втручання людини.
Це відбуватиметься без натискання кнопки, без того, щоб військовий контролював, де саме і коли буде розпочато атаку,
і без того, щоб солдат загалом ухвалював рішення про конкретну атаку.
Все це можливо завдяки штучному інтелекту.
Технологія дозволяє програмувати зброю таким чином, щоб алгоритми виконували всю роботу.
Дрон, в якого вбудований штучний інтелект, може обирати ціль за низкою ознак.
Наприклад, визначити ворожого солдата й атакувати його.
Одне з наших головних занепокоєнь полягає в тому, що ці системи, ці машини, по суті, применшують людей до кодів.
Алгоритми, системи обробляють людей, як числа.
На відміну від військового, автономна зброя не може приймати етичні рішення на полі бою.
Відповідно до міжнародного права, наприклад, ви не можете атакувати війська,
які здаються або відступають, якщо в цьому немає військової необхідності.
Рішення щодо такої необхідності - це, ймовірно, не те, що зараз можуть зробити наші системи штучного інтелекту.
А це призводить до низки етичних та юридичних питань.
А якщо справді автономна система зброї робить помилки, робить воєнні злочини, хто несе відповідальність?
Отже, ця так звана прогалина підзвітності є великою проблемою.
Технологічний прогрес особливо помітний у невеликих автономних дронах, які коштують відносно недорого.
Критики побоюються, що в майбутньому їх вироблятимуть масово.
Якщо вам не потрібні люди для нагляду, це означає, що ви можете запустити десятки тисяч або мільйони одиниць зброї.
Поки ви можете собі це дозволити, ви можете вбивати скільки завгодно людей.
Отже, ви створюєте щось потенційно більш смертоносне, ніж ядерна зброя, що, ймовірно, дешевше у виробництві.
Поборники технології кажуть, що така зброя зменшує людські втрати, бо менше солдатів гине на полі бою.
Але варто зазначити, коли ми говоримо про ці речі, що більшість конфліктів зараз відбуваються в містах.
І, звісно, цей тягар непропорційно лягає на цивільних осіб, які, звісно, мають небезпеку отримати поранення та загинути.
Чи можуть такі дрони-вбивці застосовуватися на війні в Україні?
За словами експерта зі штучного інтелекту Центру стратегічних і міжнародних досліджень у Вашингтоні Грегорі Аллена,
Росія заявляє, що має автономні технології у своєму арсеналі.
Однак експерт вважає, що російській виробник радше розкидається гучними заявами.
Якщо ж Росія справді використає цю технологію, то це буде безпрецедентний випадок,
адже досі автономну зброю застосовували лише як засіб захисту.
Використання Росією однієї з цих систем, очевидно, стало б знаковою подією
в історії військової техніки та міжнародної дипломатії.
Оскільки ця система зброї буде використана в наступальних цілях.
Отже, це не буде захисна програма. Дрони будуть вбивати з метою нападу.
На думку експерта, використання такої технології Росією стане викликом для міжнародної спільноти.
І я думаю, що виклик для міжнародної спільноти полягає в тому, що у нас є російські військові,
які навмисно бомбардують лікарні, які навмисно бомбардують заклади допомоги і навмисно вбивають цивільних.
Кількість жертв серед цивільного населення, зокрема і через автономну зброю, для них не така важлива.
Справді важливо для них буде лише, чи бачать вони потенційну вигоду на полі бою від цих технологій.
Водночас ЗСУ, якщо і використовують дрони, то насамперед для того, щоб знайти ціль, а не атакувати її, зазначає Аллен.
А в разі атаки рішення досі ухвалює українське командування.
Близько 80 держав уже не перший рік ведуть переговори з цього питання з ООН.
Основна вимога - щоб людина, а не робот, приймала остаточне рішення щодо смертельної атаки.
Однак міжнародних правил щодо нових технологій досі немає.